how are you I'm good how you doing I'm
good I know I'm in New York you know I
was a little tired but it's like this
city it doesn't allow it like I was a
little tired this morning waking up and
they were like no no no girl and like
yeah the energy of this city kind of
wakes you up how how do you like it you
have to love New York you've been here
so often on and off we love it working
on something meaningful in New York City
there's nothing like it um it's better
than any TV show any movie I mean this
pretty great yeah your own talk show is
pretty great but if I yeah and I didn't
you don't have this being you know being
a part of the Broadway Community stuff
it's like there's nothing like it that's
what I feel so lucky for so now I live
here and I can just go see shows all the
time that's amazing I'd have to like
make a trip um we both have very young
kids yours are two are two and six right
that's right okay are your kids musical
they are yeah um they are I think
they're more talented than I ever was at
their ages you know you sound like a
parent
they're they're they're no they're
exposed to it so more so much more than
I was they're so much more comfortable
than I was you know yeah they're they
really how about yours are yours I the
same you know now that you say that I
think because they grow up around it
right so they don't know any different
so they've always seen me mommy on stage
they've always come on stage when
they're baby so like I I think that they
don't it kind of shakes off the nerves a
bit for them yeah your voice is so
magical I was listening to you earlier
oh it's so good so what what was like
your favorite song as a kid what's like
what did you grow up oh you know I
remember the first grown-up song I think
we share this one the first the first
grown-up song that I really liked was
Greatest Love of All whitne Me did you
did you put it on her Pete in your room
and just keep belting it out I did yeah
yeah that's me yeah and my Mom hated it
like it's paying off now but it was a
lot of we lived in a very small
duplex yeah I don't think my neighbors
liked it either but it's like her songs
were so fun especially that one and the
message it makes you cry what a message
I uh yeah I remember there's this
there's this cassette tape that I have
from when I was a kid uh I I had my own
tape record in my room and I'm just
doing that last uh you know I'm just
looping that the final chorus
you no Prodigy no Prodigy and and you're
in your head you are Whitney so you were
like I am killing this yes oh my God and
they had to listen to
it I love I love that did you ever do
the um cuz we're the same around the
same age did you ever do the like play
and record to where you could record on
your like that was my first demo I did
like the you could kind of mess with the
tape on it and then you could record
yourself on your so I recorded over
people I was like I don't like this
anymore oh yeah I would do I would do my
own background vocals you know what I
mean was not that cool oh yeah cuz you
could like if you record it on this side
you then you put it on this side then oh
the double yes yeah and then you'd keep
flipping get the double for a minute
yeah that cost more I was like yeah that
was that's really cool you were Rich um
so so I I didn't know this but you got
your Broadway debut at 17 I I knew that
you started in rent I believe but like I
didn't know it was at 17 years old
that's very young yeah what was your
audition song for rent cuz it's such a
powerful message such a big thing I know
I sang the most inappropriate oh R&B
song that you know for this rock show
like key sweat like what were you okay
all we know oh that's a great one for
all we know we may never meet again but
you know for like so we should make
something happen
oh that's beautiful you went for like
cuz it's kind of a funny musical to do
that with though depending on what
character you're going for no I was it
was can this one rock out so much and
you're like cuning them like yeah but uh
but no that show changed my life I I
honestly like I didn't I didn't dream of
a career in the in entertainment on the
art I wanted to be in rent you know what
I mean that's kind ofic that's all I
wanted you know I thought I was going to
get it when I was 30 retire from the
show when I was like 40 and find
something else to do that's amazing
though when something hits you like that
and it changes like the trajectory of
your life yeah that was l m for me I saw
that at a young kid here it was my first
time in New York and I wept and I was
like a teenager so I did not look cool
but like I was I was like oh my God it
was so and it was Jean bjan that one got
me that song I was like oh my God anyway
it's I love when something grabs a hold
of you though and just like changes your
life in the best of ways so wait I heard
that you just got your Philadelphia is
it music Walk of Fame right I did I got
my star on the Walk of Fame
that's
incredible what was the moment like for
you that's like where you're from that's
cool you know I it it was really it
really touched me um to Philadelphia has
meant the world to me you know um and so
you don't I I never considered that
maybe I might mean something to
Philadelphia too you know out here
that's a nice way to put
it people from uh people from my my
childhood and and from grade school
showed up to the to the ceremony which I
also wasn't expecting it was pretty
meaningful that's pretty cool man when
you run into people like you knew when
you're were a kid and it's just like
what happened I can't believe this
happened you know like everybody has
this dream like to be a part of this
industry and especially creative people
you know and we're very lucky amen yeah
I know blessed you are now back in New
York City you're back on Broadway so how
do how do you like it what's the show
like how's it going oh loving it purely
Victorious yes it's uh show called purly
Victorious it hasn't been on Broadway in
62 years we brought this this uh
brilliant AI Davis play great he's a
great American a great writer you guys
know him um and we we brought this play
back revived this play after 62 years
and it is just it's so joyful it's um
connecting with people it's found an
audience we've been extended another
month at the music box theater yeah it's
so cool I love the Wardrobe for it too
the time that it is it's very cool yeah
it's um you know pearly Victorious I
think about Linn Manuel a lot you know
when I'm doing this show uh we got two
of them today but I I think about Li
well because you know it's these two
young writers that um writing about
different times allbe at different times
writing about America writing about
their country and what it means to be an
American very patriotic shows you should
go see like uh pearly Victorious MAA and
Hamilton at night yeah that that's it's
very important though because I think a
lot of kids got them into history as
well like that's so funny that something
like on Broadway did that but a lot of I
was like wait what what are yall talking
about and just sparked a different kind
of if if we only taught like that right
in school and stuff but you are in
theater so there you go um so um I have
to say I thought this was kind of crazy
so you one of your theater classes was
actually taught by did Billy Porter did
he step in for a bit of it he did yes
Billy uh I went to a um the college I
went to was Carnegie melon University
and Billy's also a Carnegie I love him
he's the best yeah and yeah Billy came
junior year and taught uh for half a
semester and he was like the most impact
I don't want to make any of my teachers
any mean anyone else not doing that yet
really was he was an exceptional teacher
because he was a hero too you he was a
hero before then and he just came and
and changed our lives really yeah oh
that's magical having a teacher like
that as well oh I love that you got all
that experience as a kid that's why
you're an amazing human um so also why
you're an amazing human is I recently
heard that you love um journaling I'm a
huge Journal kid now I get a little
nervous about someone finding it but I
know yeah cuz that's happened to me
before someone found it and like read it
and then accused me of like what was in
it I was like you got my that's my mess
I was like wait what I was like you
jumped in that tornado that's on you
like yeah but like I love it though it
makes me feel good to get it out yeah it
kind of it's a yeah another thing that's
you know changing your change will
change your life I started waking up an
hour and a half to two hours before my
wife and my kids and so you have you
time yes my me time yeah I Journal I do
my yoga I drink my coffee and stuff and
it's it's a chance for me to find out
where I am and uh before the day starts
rushing in and I've you know I've had
realizations for for the record you know
I I went through one of those really
tough Seasons that's kind of waiting for
everybody you know you haven't been
through it yet just wait it's coming you
know but you know one of those seasons
and I Journal through the whole thing
and I really was just honestly trying to
make it to the other side of that yeah
and I I never was um thinking that I
would use it creatively in any way but
yeah it dawned on me uh this one day as
I was listening to music and you know
music was such a balm and such a um
Guiding Light that time it was like oh
I'm supposed to use this I'm supposed to
write about about this you know if I'm
supposed to make the record that I
needed to listen to you know about going
through this yeah that's what I that's
like the goal right that's something you
would want to get through as well like
um well when Leslie um actually was
making his album Mister he wrote in his
journal finish the task God needs some
folks who are willing and courageous
enough to finish what they started
especially after he starts them I love
that it's so beautiful do you feel like
that still resonates
yeah I mean every now and again that
because the journey is long you know
it's a long journey and you can lose
your way sometimes in the middle um I I
wrote that down because I I needed to
remember it you know I needed to almost
remind yourself yeah that's right that
it's like um it's not always about
judging yourself and what you think is
good and what you think is worthy finish
it finish the task you know the the
inspiration is Holy the inspiration to
start something I think you know those
things are like they they come from
somewhere and to honor that original
inspiration and the the least you can do
is finish the task as best you can thank
you a I agree with that so tell me about
your new album this is I was listening
to it last night it's it's different
like than what I'm used to like hearing
it's so cool it's different it's got
especially how you're performing it
today because I also heard him earlier
um I love it how it's starting I feel
like you should release that version of
it as well it's so great but what what
is the the reason like why did you need
to do this album um well uh I mean
recording is my is my favorite thing to
do other than broadway you know and
doing talk shows uh good
answer I I love making these albums and
you know the truth is I we were almost
finished a whole other record you know
and then kind of Life came and we I went
through this um traumatic you know
experience in my life seon one of those
times and um when when I got back to
recording you know I'm sure you've been
through this too you go back to sing
those old songs and you're like I can't
even sing those anymore I got to write
yeah all new stuff so this was this was
just that it was um it's really you know
I had the realization really about
journaling that whole thing waking up an
hour and a half earlier all that stuff
like it was three or four months into
doing that that I realized what I'm
actually doing is loving myself
this is what it looks like you know man
and if you don't really know that like
until your eyes are open to that so this
is an album uh sort of uh about that
process about that process of of firstly
learning how to love your damn self you
know it's the only way I have a prayer
cuz we're our worst critics yeah y my
God it's the only way that I have a
chance of having Grace with with um my
dear ones my beloved ones as if I have
some for myself absolutely and I don't
know if you can show it unless you can
like feel it for yourself as well like
you can't project it so your song that's
a good segue so it's called loved the
one you're doing today is that kind of
the inspiration behind that yeah I you
know I I was um there's this I'm sure
you've had this too like you know this
realization about the flexibility of
time when you have kids you know there's
times when I'm looking at my son and I
and I almost feel like I'm looking at
myself and I can almost feel you know
it'll be a blink before see I'm an old
man especially my daughter and I'm like
oh my God I can see you at 20 this is
scary you know anyway it's about that
and I was feeling you know kind of
connected to my to my grandparents even
though they're no longer here and it's
about that there's a refrain in the song
um show them you've been loved show them
how I loved you you know if you've if
you've Been Loved by anybody in your
life it's like you know when you're
looking for the courage to take that
next step when you're looking up
sometimes the courage to you know go out
and and face the world one more time
it's like what you you know if you don't
have it within yourself um I just I
heard my grandparents saying that show
show the world that we loved you yeah
and show them what love looks like and
feels like yeah um stay with us
everybody because Leslie will be singing
later in the show you do not want to
miss it's beautiful his new album is
called when a kuner dies it's out
[Music]
now
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home